insuffisante dans une province
où le taux d'inflation dépasse
la moyen
- J'ai fait un carré,
chchcheesecake".
- Ce n'est qu'un gâteau
au fromage. Mais pour Solange
Thébeau, faire un ououououououo.
- J'achète le fromage.
Après ça, bien là, peut-être
une autre journée, je vais aller
acheter des cerises puis
Je peux pas tout acheter
d'un paquet : c'est trop cher.
- C'est d'ailleurs pour mieux
affronter la hausse des prix
des aliments et du carburant5 50
Néo-Brunswickois à faible revenu
recevront un chèque
du gouvernement provincial :
225 $ par personne ou ûûûûûûûûûl
de l'opération : 20 millions $.
225 $, qu'est-ce que ça va
changer pour vous?
Pas grand-chose.
Quelques morceaux à acheter,
puis ce sera tout.
insuffisante, admet le pre
ministre, mais le maximum
offrir sans hausser les impôts,
souligne
DAVID COON, chef, Parti vert
du Nouveau-Brunswick
- Ce n'est pas suffisant,
pas du tout. C'est juste
une fois seulement.
- Mais pour l'opposition,
les troupes de Blaine Higgs
doivent en faire plus.
ROGER MELANSON, chef intérim,
Parti libéral du N.-B.
- On cplplplplplein de gens qui
font en moyenne une cinquantaine
de milles de dollars par année.
Ils n'ont pas d'aide aujourd'hui
avec cette annonce.
- C'est en fait moins de 10 %
de la population qui est visée
par la mesure. Une approche
différente de celle du Québec,
où tous les travailleurs
enenenenent moins de 100 000 $
par année ont droit à une aide
financière.
PIERRE-MARCEL DESJARDINS,
économiste
- C'est qu'il faut être prudent.
Si on a des mesures
plus universelles qui couvrent
un plus grand nombre de gens,
en leur transférant de l'argentr
la consommation, ça risque
d'augmenter les pressions
inflationnistes.
- Des pressions que Solange
ressent au quotidien
et qui n'ont, pour elle,
rien de rassurant.
- Je me dis : il faut
que j'y aille de mois en mois
pour voir ce qui va arriver.
Je me couche le soir, puis
je pense : j'espère que demain,
ça va aller mieux.
- Ici Mathieu Papillon,
Radio-Canada, St-Louis-De-Ke